[Música]
existe un gran misterio mediambiental
que comienza con un detalle
Aparentemente trivial pero que revela un
desastre global de proporciones
incalculables un día te das cuenta de
que la miel que htas en tu tostada
matutina es más cara en lugar de pasarte
a la mermelada investigas la razón del
aumento de precio lo que descubres es
impactante el número de domesticadas en
Estados Unidos ha disminuido a un ritmo
alarmante la caída es tan grande que no
puede deberse solo a las causas
habituales de muerte de las abejas
enfermedades parásitos o desnutrición en
la escena típica del crimen apenas hay
abejas adultas en las colmenas salvo
quizás la solitaria reina y unas pocas
supervivientes las colmenas están llenas
de comida sin tocar y de larvas sin
hacer lo que indica que las adultas se
marcharon sin esperar a que nacieran
pero lo realmente inquietante es que no
hay restos de abejas muertas o
moribundas en las proximidades tal vez
olvidaron el camino de vuelta a La
Colmena o simplemente
desaparecieron estas misteriosas
desapariciones no son nuevas los seres
humanos han estado recolectando miel
durante siglos pero no fue hasta que los
colonizadores europeos del siglo XV
introdujeron una subespecie la apis
melífera que domesticamos a las abejas
desde el siglo XIX los apicultores han
registrado desapariciones masivas izadas
con misteriosos nombres como síndrome de
la despoblación disminución de primavera
o colapso de otoño pero cuando en 2006
estas desapariciones afectaron a más de
la mitad de las colmenas de Estados
Unidos el fenómeno tomó un nuevo nombre
el síndrome de colapso de la colonia ccd
en inglés lo más preocupante de este
misterio no es que tengamos que volver a
echarle azúcar al té criamos a las
abejas por su miel pero también
polinizan nuestras cosechas a escala
Industrial lo que genera cerca de un
tercio de la producción de alimentos en
los Estados Unidos Entonces dónde está
el responsable de esta desgracia Estos
son tres de los posibles culpables
prueba a plagas y enfermedades la más
infame es la barroa un diminuto acaro
rojo que no solo invade coloni y se
alimenta de abejas sino que también
transmite patógenos que atrofian su
desarrollo y acortan sus vidas prueba B
la genética la abeja reina es el corazón
de una Colmena sana pero hoy en día
millones de abejas reinas de las menas
comerciales se han criado a partir de
unas pocas reinas lo que aumenta la
preocupación sobre la falta de
diversidad genética algo que podría
debilitar las defensas de las abejas
frente a los patógenos y las plagas
prueba c los productos químicos los
pesticidas usados en Las colmenas y en
los cultivos para protegerlos de los
parásitos podrían estar introduciéndose
en la comida y el agua que consumen las
abejas Los investigadores han
descubierto que algunos pesticidas
afectan a la capacidad de las abejas
para producir miel así que tenemos un un
expediente con muchas pistas pero sin
indicadores claros en realidad los
científicos los verdaderos detectives
del caso no se ponen de acuerdo sobre
las causas de este síndrome por ahora
podemos asumir que es resultado de
varios factores las abejas no están
necesariamente en peligro de extinción
pero menos abejas es igual a menos
polinización y alimentos más caros Así
que es crucial que los científicos
resuelvan el misterio de las abejas
desaparecidas porque la escasez de
cosechas podría ser realmente un una
punzada
[Música]
aguda